الحرب بين البلدين في كل شيء حتى في القوه
الناعمه التي كانت احد اهم اسباب تفوق
واشنطن في الحرب البارده اليوم تنافسها
بكين تاريخيا اعتمدت القوى الناعمه
الامريكيه بشكل الرئيسي على افلامها التي
اعتبر المنتج والتر ونر ان كل فيلم منها
بمثابه السفير امريكي لكن هوليود فقدت
بريقها امام لاعب جديد وغير متوقع العاب
الفيديو فقط في عام 2021 حقق سوق العاب
الفيديو العالمي عائدات بلغت 180 مليار
دولار طب هو على هوليود وصناعه الموسيقى
مجتمعين سوق احتكرته اليابان والولايات
المتحده لكن دخلت الصين على خط المنافسه
وبقوه انتجت سته من افضل 20 لعبه للهواتف
الجوال العام الماضي بما في ذلك من افضل
ثلاث العاب وكما هو الحال مع تيك توك ينظر
الى الالعاب الصينيه في واشنطن على انها
ادوات لجمع البيانات الاسم وتاريخ الميلاد
وتفاصيل الدفع او مقاطع صوتيه مسجله في
عام 2020 فرضت الخزانه الامريكيه غرامه
قدرها 275 مليون دولار على شركه
جزئيا لشركه الصينيه والسبب جمع بيانات
الاطفال بشكل غير قانوني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات